bonsoir à tous je dis 21 décembre
bienvenue dans cette nouvelle édition
d'information locale sur tv 78 tout de
suite les titres de ce set 8 journal
conseil communautaire ce soir pour saint
quentin en yvelines
à l'ordre du jour notamment le vote pour
la fusion des mission locale de
l'agglomération avec celle de plaisir
5000 jeunes sont concernés du territoire
les précisions à suivre
emmanuel macron président de la
république est large victoire de la
république en marche aux législatives
effritement des partis traditionnels
2017 a livré ses verdicts
est ce pour autant une année qui a tout
bousculé sur le champ de la politique
elle nous poserons la question à
stéphane minson professeur de droit
public à sciences po saint germain en
laye et a lu vs cuche
et puis c'est bientôt noël c'est bientôt
le début des fêtes
pendant cette période il n'y a pas que
le père noël qui s'affairent à les
élèves de l'école les baissière à
maurepas sont aussi amis à la main à la
pâte aujourd'hui avec un atelier marché
noël
quatremer va des yvelines et de
l'essonne qui équilibre qui écrivent au
premier ministre edouard philippe
parmi eux bertrand au lion édile ps de
magny les hameaux dans ce courrier les
élus ont fait part de leur inquiétude
concernant l'arrivée de la ligne 18 à
l'horizon 2030 entre versailles et
l'aéroport d'orly ils sont tous
concernés par le passage du tronçon en
aérien sur leur commune elle est maire
demande que des alternatives à ce viaduc
de 13 km en pleine terre agricole soit
étudiée c'est un peu l'arlésienne pour
rambouillet mais peut-être plus pour
longtemps le doublement de la route
nationale 10 au niveau de la ville du
sud yvelines devrait voir le jour
une première tranche de travaux a été
votée en ce sens pour le printemps en
objectif mettre fin à ce point noir du
trafic coût total de ce chantier est 2,5
millions d'euros financé en partie par
l'agglomération rambouillet territoire
est la délibération sera votée ce jeudi
soir en conseil communautaire de saint
quentin en yvelines les mission locale
de l'agglomération et 2
désir vont fusionner ou 1er janvier 2018
suite à une décision d'état cette mesure
concerne plus de 5000 jeunes de 16 à 25
ans sur ce territoire les détails avec
ce sujet denis calais nedo une réunion
pour préparer la fusion les deux
missions locales de plaisir et de saint
quentin en yvelines se sont retrouvés au
golf national ce mardi 19 décembre
objectif échanger sur le mariage entre
les structures prévues pour le 1er
janvier 2018 c'est important parce que
finalement à plaisir on est un peu plus
éloignés qu'ils aux antennes les unes
des autres
donc on se connaît pas du tout et pour
moi qui suis une nouvelle à plaisir
depuis un an c'est
les nouvelles rencontres le rendez vous
a également permis d'expliquer la mesure
qui sera voté au prochain conseil
communautaire de saint quentin en
yvelines ce jeudi 21 décembre
la fusion est plutôt une fusion
absorption en créant une nouvelle
structure sera mis beaucoup plus de
temps
et qu'est ce qu'on aurait fait en effet
du service à rendre au public est ce
qu'on aurait fait aussi des salariés qui
travaillent pour
les jeunes en difficulté à la sortie de
ce rendez-vous les quarante trois
employés présents ont accueilli cette
fusion absorption avec enthousiasme donc
plus d'idées peut-être plus de moyens
moyens financiers moyens humains et puis
peut-être plus en plus de sites où les
jeunes peuvent se déplacer aussi la
fusion sera intéressante pour les jeunes
de tout le bassin de saint quentin en
yvelines qui auront tous en fait les
mêmes prestations les mêmes services
car je n'habite plaisir ou quinze jeunes
habitent par exemple voisins le
bretonneux
tous ces jeunes là on rend le même
service sur seul sur le même territoire
ce qui n'était pas spécialement le cas
aujourd'hui
au total cette fusion concernera plus de
5000 jeunes déscolarisés âgés de 16 à 25
ans présents sur le territoire saint
quentinois
2010 est une année incontestablement au
politique avec toutes les échéances
électorales l'ascension rapide des
manuels macron devenu en mai président
de la république l'effritement des
grands partis traditionnels à un niveau
plus local la large victoire de la
république en marche aux législatives
onze des douze circonscriptions a gagné
remporté sur les yvelines bonsoir
stéphane minson en soit vous êtes
professeur de droit public à sciences po
saint germain en laye également à
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines avec vous on va se demander si
2010 est une année qui a finalement tout
chambouler sur le paysage dans le
paysage politique
déjà plus que les parties se sont aussi
des hommes qui sont tombées pendant
cette année 2010 est françois hollande
avant même de pouvoir se représenter à
la présidentielle nicolas sarkozy alain
juppé manuel valls est également
françois fillon peut on peut en citer
d'autres
est ce qu'on avait vu pareil coup de
balai dans la vème république
ça a pu arriver alors ça a pu arriver
mais si vous voulez à des instants
historiques à des instants charnière je
pense par exemple dans une moindre
mesure à 1958 fondations d'un cinquième
république qui a apporté un personnel
politique très très renouvelée je pense
aussi à dans une moindre mesure à 1974
ce qu'on appelait la petite alternance
avec l'élection de giscard d'estaing et
puis évidemment à mai 1981 avec
l'apparition de nouvelles têtes de
nouvelles personnes mais dans une telle
ampleur est dans un tel fracas si j'ose
dire c'est vrai que ça ne c'est sous la
vème république jamais produit 2010 est
marquée bien sûr par l'élection d'
emmanuel macron à la présidence de la
public un président qui a affiché la
couleur dès le début il voulait
renouveler les pratiques politiques avec
son fameux terme de la société civile
impliquées la société civile dans ces
décisions un peu plus de six mois après
son élection est ce que le pari est
gagné pour vous il ya peut-être un
renouvellement du style mais il ya une
forme de paradoxe c'est à dire que on
n'a jamais eu
on le sait on l'a dit et redit un
président de république aussi jeune et
c'est symboliquement très fort mais
d'autre part et c'est l'autre aspect du
paradoxe c'est que ce président de la
république très jeune renoue en fait
semble renouer avec la lettre de la
constitution de la vème république avec
une pratique assez assez gaullienne
finalement des institutions avec un
président jupitérien c'est-à-dire un
président qui s'occupe de l'essentiel
qui est censée ne s'occuper que de
l'essentiel fait que certains lui
reprochent d de ressusciter quelques
pratiques anciennes au niveau politique
un président qui s'occupe surtout de
politique extérieure au point que le
ministre des affaires étrangères qui est
pourtant une personnalité assez forte
monsieur le drian 20 n'apparaît que très
secondairement et puis un président qui
s'occupe aussi de défense nationale de
l'armée etc
donc voilà des pratiques renouvelée mais
finalement dans un cadre très
traditionnel deux grands partis aussi
qui s'effrite les républicains le parti
socialiste avec aussi des tensions en
interne c'est le cas aussi au niveau
local li république a d'abord qui on
peut dire sauve les meubles avec les
sénatoriales en conservant 146 sièges au
sénat mais aux législatives il ya eu un
vrai raz-de-marée de la république en
marche dans les yvelines un département
qui est ancrée est traditionnellement à
droite et là il ya eu onze des douze
circonscriptions qui ont été remportés
par la république en de marché sont
alliés du modem oui absolument
le
le problème c'est qu'on peut pas
vraiment comparer s'ils voulaient les
sénatoriales ont toujours un effet un
effet retard c'est à dire que la
conséquence des municipales voilà les
sénatoriales en réalité se joue
essentiellement aux élections
municipales la droite traditionnelle
tient l'essentiel les mairies et des
conseils municipaux dans les yvelines et
dans france c'est le cas aussi donc il
était normal peau sénatoriales on
retrouve si vous voulez un résultat de
ce genre la revanche pour les
législatives
là en effet on peut parler au moins dans
les yvelines et au delà sur plan
national d'un véritable raz-de-marée
ça ne devrait de l'autre côté le parti
socialiste quasiment rayées de la carte
le parti socialiste quasiment rayées de
la carte j'allais dire il fallait s'y
attendre on s'y attendait ça n'a pas été
une surprise puisque le parti socialiste
au fond et est en crise depuis déjà pas
mal d'années le quinquennat hollande n'a
rien arrangé avec le phénomène de ce
qu'on a appelé les frondeurs vous le
savez phénomène d'éclatement et de
délitement
il faut que le parti socialiste alors
j'ai l'impression que c'est que nous y
sommes touche le faut pour qu'il puisse
à un moment un autre se renouveler alors
est-ce que du coup ce chamboule tout va
durer dans le temps est ce que au
contraire les vieux partis ou ont ré
émerger plus tard est-ce que c'est ça
peut être durable ce changement
politique alors à mon avis ça s'inscrit
de manière ça a l'air de s'inscrire de
manière et c'est durable
on n'est pas au bout on ne sait pas
encore ce que l'avenir fanou va nous
réserver notamment sur la stabilisation
et l'ancrage de la république en marche
on le verra au prochain scrutin qui sera
les élections européennes
on le verra aussi et surtout aux
élections locales notamment aux
élections municipales
le groupe i en 2019 et les prochaines
élections dès 2020 exactement si la
république en marche parvient à
s'implanter dans le territoire ou pas et
de quelle manière
mais à côté de cela n'oublions pas quand
même que
le front national a réalisé un score
très important aux élections pour à
l'élection présidentielle pas loin de
plus même de 7 millions de voix je crois
au premier tour ce qui est considérable
donc l'avenir du front national au sein
duquel la légitimité de marine le pen
est assez contesté est aussi aussi
importants inscrits et il nous reste un
peu plus d'une minute derrière question
ce champ bouton vous l'expliquez comment
en tant que spécialiste la politique
est-ce qu'il ya aussi une vraie volonté
française d'un renouvellement des
déceptions des de la droite de la gauche
qui peuvent expliquer bien se chambrent
incontestablement une volonté de
renouvellement mais une volonté de
renouvellement qui a quasi permanente 1
dans l'opinion publique
au point que l'on les français se disent
parfois le renouvellement pourrait
passer par une victoire de marine le pen
puisqu'on les a tous essayé sauf elle
sauf qu'ici il ya une nouvelle tête qui
a émergé celle d' emmanuel macron et qui
a provoqué vraiment un véritable
renouvellement de fond mais remarqué
aussi que dans le même temps la réaction
des français était assez mitigé au
regard par exemple du supposé ont duré l
amateurisme des nouveaux députés où on a
raillé leur inexpérience et c'est donc
c'est toujours c'est toujours assez
assez partagés assez paradoxal sentiment
des français
à surveiller donc sur 2018 merci à
stéphane mention d'avoir été avec nous
avec plaisir professeur de droit public
à sciences po saint germain en laye à
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines
suite et fin maintenant de notre dossier
de la rédaction nous vous présentions
toute cette semaine les yvelinois de
2017 focus ce soir sur michel bernat qui
oeuvrent au sein de la croix rouge
française depuis plus de dix ans une
fois par semaine ils effectuent des
maraudes dans les yvelines et à travers
son action elle c'est tout le travail
des bénévoles de cette association que
nous avons voulu mettre en avant
elle nous les avons suivis au cours
d'une soirée dans le territoire
en train de préparer le matériel pour
nécessaire pour la maraude des produits
alimentaires des couvertures ou encore
des vêtements michel bernard prépare
aussi de l'eau chaude la base des
boissons destinées aux personnes sans
domicile un bien nécessaire en hiver
pour se réchauffer michel est bénévole à
la croix rouge il a rejoint
l'association en 2006 lorsqu'il prend sa
retraite
ils commencent les maraudes deux ans
après voilà neuf ans qu'il est engagé
auprès des personnes dans le besoin
je pense que jusque-là on essuie
l'humanité pourquoi pas essayer
l'humanité ce qu'on apprend on s'est
aperçu que l'humanité ça ne marche pas
en fait une pointe d'humour pour montrer
un engagement social allant de soi pour
michel ce soir il fait équipe avec amine
l'heure est au changement
le vivant sur la dessus avant de partir
michel contacter la régulation du 115
ce service du samu social directement en
lien avec les personnes sans abri
oriente les bénévoles sur le terrain on
va jusqu'à la mairie d'elancourt visite
de personnes qui sont généralement sous
le théâtre du prisme
mais je crois avoir une information
comme quoi ils ont été logés donc on va
quand même allé vérifier première
mission de la soirée à elancourt dans le
quartier 17 marc michel et amine vont
vérifier la situation de deux personnes
vivant sous l'escalier du prisme
finalement l'information de michel était
bonne les personnes ont été relogées par
la mairie d'elancourt là on a une
nouvelle mission donc on va voir nos
bénéficiaires qui est un peu un habitué
qui se trouve à l'église des sources en
automne au retour aux véhicules et
direction montigny le bretonneux pour
porter assistance à georges lors de la
dernière visite de michelle ce sans abri
lui avait demandé des vêtements
les bénévoles de la croix rouge vont lui
donner des shows sur un pull et de la
nourriture
non on avait foulé la crevette georges a
bénéficié d'une aide vestimentaires et
alimentaires
michel fait un bilan téléphonique à la
régulation avant de recevoir une
nouvelle mission une personne située à
saint cyr l'école
il s'agit d'el feige qui reçoit des
produits alimentaires mais pas seulement
en plus d'une aide sociale inss za et
puis nous parler c'est lorsqu'on n'a pas
l'occasion de parler honnêtement c'est
franchement c'est vrai c'est ils sont là
quand même pour nous donner un bon coup
de main quoi l'objectif de la maraude en
elle-même en fait c'est d'apporter une
aide d'urgence
j'en appelle le 115 dans les quelques
heures qui suivent ou dans les
commettants qui suivront leur apportent
leur aide les gens le monde après saint
cyr l'école michel et amine prennent la
direction des essarts le roi
la maraude ne fait que commencer elle va
durer jusqu'à minuit
ac le traité de libre échange entre
l'union européenne et le canada le 7 1
est entré en vigueur provisoirement le
21 septembre dernier pour une
application complète maintenant elle
doit être ratifié par l'ensemble des
parlements nationaux et régionaux de
l'union européenne et côté secteur
agricole les associés des associations
aussi sont inquiets face aux c'est à un
exemple 60 mille tonnes de boeuf
canadien pourrait arriver sur le
territoire l'union européenne et ça sans
droits de douane bonsoir antonin moulin
soir vous êtes le responsable
communication de la sauce régale c'est
une association guyancourt toit ce qui a
été créé l'an passé en 2016 il ya
quelques semaines vous ai fait parvenir
aux députés de votre circonscription la
première circonscription des yvelines
ce député c'est didier baichère voulait
fait parvenir un courrier un courrier
dans lequel vous lui demander de
s'opposer
voilà fermement à ce traité du ceta
quand il sera discuté à l'assemblée
nationale puisqu'il doit être encore
ratifié à l'assemblée nationale pourquoi
avoir entamé cette démarche alors la
filière agricole
et menacer les initiatives vert pour
l'agriculture biologique sont sont
largement menacés par ce nouveau traité
de libre-échange qui va accroître la
concurrence et la pression sur
l'ensemble de la filière
la filière biologique a besoin d'être
soutenu et a besoin de solidarité et le
ceta c'est exactement l'inversé les
politiques d'achat local vont être
empêché des tribunaux arbitraux vont
être mis en place pour empêcher les
états de faire une politique locale et
c'est très embêtant ça menace vraiment
la reconversion de notre agriculture
parce qu'il ya urgence le climat le
réchauffement climatique est un sujet de
plus en plus urgent est donc nous ce
qu'on pense c'est qu'il faut agir
maintenant et nous demandons à notre
député didier baichère de prendre ses
responsabilités suite au grenelle de
l'alimentation
suite à l'accord de la coop 21 signe à
paris de dire exposées des états
généraux de l'alimentation ça s'est
déroulé en scène ça s'est déroulé la
concertation c'est terminé récemment le
croyais et en date du 23 octobre 2010 n
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous avez reçu une
réponse du député
alors non on n'a eu aucun pas de
réaction publique de monsieur le député
nous serions vraiment satisfaits s'ils
pouvaient nous répondre parce que quand
même nous avons certains d'entre nous
avons voté pour lui et revoilà ce serait
bien de donner des gages aux électeurs
pour peut-être voter pour lui une
prochaine fois parce que là c'est ça va
dans le sens inverse des intérêts de ses
électeurs qui ont besoin d'un territoire
avec des ressources et une autonomie
alimentaire et surtout une alimentation
saine parce que ça met en branle
aussi les normes environnementales et
les normes sanitaires qui ne seront pas
les nôtres pas celle de
la france qui sont des normes exigeantes
et importante avec le traité de libre
échange il ya plus de contrôles on l'a
compris peser des craintes dans le sens
canada union européenne pourtant dans
l'autre soit le lente l'autre sens
pardon europe vers le canada pourrait se
dire que par exemple des producteurs
pour être avantagé les producteurs
laitiers notamment qui jouissent
d'appellation européenne cantal morbier
et qui pourrait avoir une place de choix
au canada qui pourrait trouver aussi un
public au canada
et pourquoi les agriculteurs canadiens
ne fournirait pas le canada les
agriculteurs français leveaux la france
à chacun doit rester sur son très
simplement
une question de bon sens en termes de
réduction des gaz à effet de serre pour
protéger la planète parce que si on
continue comme ça la surchauffe est
assurée c'est une question de bon sens
et j'espère que pour une fois les
parlementaires voteront avec du bon sens
c'est même pas une question de droite ou
de gauche est une question de bon sens
nous à la sauce régal ça fait depuis un
an et demi concret de la solidarité sur
notre territoire et le sait placer juste
linverse c'est l'accroissement de la
compétition et les salles met en péril
toute l'économie locale
et maintenant que le traité est ratifié
par l'ue ratifié provisoirement il a
appliqué provisoirement par l'union
européenne quelles sont finalement vos
espoirs que l'assemblée nationale ne la
ratifient pas bien sûr l'assemblée
nationale ne doit pas la ratifier et en
logiquement même l'on devrait avoir un
référendum parce que c'est une décision
sur très importantes qui concernent tout
le peuple français et tous les habitants
de tous les territoires et on devrait
avoir notre mot à dire
et en l'occurrence pour le coup pour
l'instant ce n'est pas le cas pourtant
il ya une mobilisation en marche pour
demander ce référendum et je pense qu'il
serait important de d'écouter cette
revendication un mot rapide ne reste pas
beaucoup de temps sur l'association la
sauce régal qui a été créée on l'a dit
l'an passé à guyancourt et et qui a pour
but vous l'avez rappelé promouvoir une
alimentation pardon locale une
alimentation saine
oui tout à fait et d'ailleurs nous
enchaînons sur une la prochaine campagne
en février qui touchera la
relocalisation de l'agriculture mais pas
seulement de tout ce qui la citoyenneté
l'énergie etc
la sociabilité et voilà donc on engage
notre député à ne pas faire l' inverse
de ce que font les habitants de basse
qu'il ya des gens qui se mobilisent
monsieur le député à l'exercice du
pouvoir pour lui eh bien j'espère qu'il
en fera bon usage
voilà et vous avez ouvert récemment
on avait parlé sur télé soit 118 une
épicerie participative puisqu'ils durent
autoire exactement qui est un redonne
vie au quartier
ça va permettre de créer du lien au
niveau du quartier et surtout
d'encourager les producteurs locaux à
écouler l'ensemble de leurs stocks et
nous ce qu'on fait c'est effectivement
faire sortir les producteurs locaux du
marché parce qu'il est trop
concurrentiel il ya trop de pression
concurrentielle et le ceta va exerce
exacerbée ça si il est voté merci en
tout cas un boulard d'avoir été avec
nous je le rappelle responsable
communication de la sauce régal et pour
plus d'informations sur cette
association vous pouvez vous rendre sur
le site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran
le sport un tournoi de football
caritatif pour la création d'entreprise
il a été organisée samedi dernier à
poissy par positive planète
l'association aide les porteurs de
projets de banlieue à créer et
développer leur société
un coup de pouce est nécessaire pour
faire aboutir ses projets une cagnotte
est d'ailleurs organisée à ce sujet
jusqu'au 23 janvier 2 140 archers
présents le tournoi de tir à l'arc de
guyancourt se tenait au gymnase maurice
baquet samedi 16 et dimanche 17 décembre
cinquième édition dans un format duel
entre les archers après une phase de
qualification un sujet de nicolas
d'android ils sont champions d'europe en
salle par équipes valentin ripaud et
thomas chiron ont participé au concours
de tir à l'arc organisé par les archers
de guyancourt une compétition pour se
tester en vue de la prochaine saison
cette année je passais seniors et niveau
quand même un peu plus élevé il ya
beaucoup plus de monde donc c'est quand
même mieux de faire ces petits
changements là qui donnera peut-être le
point en plus qu'il manquera où le petit
détail
mon objectif en venant ici c'est
premièrement de me préparer pour la
suite et après on sait faire le maximum
de matchs possible et je pense que je
peux aller au bout et thomas girod a
accompli son objectif il a remporté le
tournoi catégorie senior arc classique
un format sur le modèle des compétitions
internationales avec des duels entre les
archers préparer tous les sportifs de
haut niveau
aux championnats régionaux france ou
voire internationaux on a mis en place
cette compétition à côté des
professionnels les archers amateurs
relèvent leur niveau du club d'elancourt
emilie coupé utilise un arc à poulies la
spécificité une puissance supérieure à
l'arc classique car comme j'ai eu des
petits soucis de santé j'ai changé de
matériel à la dernière minute donc c'est
me faire plaisir et vraiment essayé de
me focaliser sur les proies sans
pression avec un nouvel arc à poulies
emilie a remporté le tournoi dans sa
catégorie
à j - 4 avant noël il n'y a pas que le
père noël qui est impliqué pendant cette
période l'école maternelle est baissière
de maurepas les élèves de grande section
ont préparé avec leurs enseignantes à
marcher noël ils ont réalisé quelques
travaux mais aussi d un gâteau ils ont
réalisé quelques gags cadeaux et aussi
des gâteaux on va y arriver à dont la
vente servira à alimenter les caisses de
l'école tout cela aussi pour développer
un projet pédagogique camille lambert et
wilfrid richy jour de marché de noël
pour cette école de maurepas des maracas
des bâtons de pluie ou encore des sapins
confectionnés par les enfants de l'école
maternelle est vendu aux parents tout
cela aura nécessité plusieurs jours de
préparation
après le chant de noël place aux
activités manuelles ce matin cet atelier
petit gâteau pour les élèves de la
grande section avec la directrice et de
quelques mamans les petites mains
s'activent
qu'est-ce que tu es en train de faire
jimena mélange trois pattes vous
préparer quoi alors comment vous les
avez préparé ses gâteaux comment on fait
des gâteaux sont quelle forme le gâteau
il forme de bonhomme en pain de disques
de tortues ou alors des sapins bien
préparé des gâteaux
oui c'est lesquels tu es préféré c'est
qu'ils songent au cola et après la
confection
vient l'étape cruciale de la cuisson
son sage appliquée oui il aime beaucoup
ça la cuisine tu as été sage
c'est vrai tu étais très sage et louis
derrière ces ateliers un projet
pédagogique pour les enseignants il
s'agissait aussi de préparer un marché
de noël liées au thème de cette année la
musique on a créé donc la peinture du
collage du découpage n'est pas y est
pour que ça brille avec soit joli on est
parti vraiment sur un gros projet
musique nous devons être là c'est parti
sur paris pour voir un concert qu'ils
sont vraiment très impliqué dans le
projet donc créer leur propre instrument
ça a été vraiment facile de les
impliquer
c'est une classe très performante donc
on a réalisé vraiment des beaux objets
des élèves et des enseignants satisfait
du travail accompli
reste maintenant à savoir si le père
noël a bien eu droit de déguster ses
gâteaux au pied des sapins lors de sa
distribution de cadeaux
vous l'avez vu avec ce sujet notre
rédacteur en chef qui est retombé en
enfance
enfin noël avait pris un peu d'avancé à
magny les hameaux le week-end dernier le
parvis de l'hôtel de ville était en fait
une manifestation traditionnelle qui a
encore réuni de nombreux visiteurs
clôture de ce journal avec nicolas
d'andry et camille lambert
gourmandise et ateliers créatifs le
parvis de l'hôtel de ville de magny les
hameaux s'est transformé en grande fête
un moyen de célébrer noël avant l'heure
en famille nous avons fait maquillage on
a fait fabrication de cartes avec des
gommettes océan bas de la maison c'est
convivial c'est génial pour les enfants
et ils font plein d'activités on vient
quasiment tous les ans c'est le c'est un
petit peu le démarrage des festivités un
goûter géant et des animations
organisées par la ville cet événement
est devenu incontournable
les gens viennent vraiment d'année en
année avec les enfants avec les petits
enfants ont réuni ici
plusieurs milliers de personnes pendant
tout l'après midi c'est
noël les fêtes de fin d'année avant
l'heure tout simplement est accessible à
tout le monde
des festivités avec un point d'orgue à
la venue tant attendue du père noël
ici il y avait des gens gentils deux
enfants sages
est ce que c'est vrai
viens tous les ans sur le parvis pour
pourvoir le père noël je prends quand
même toujours un peu de temps pour venir
voir les gens dans les villes pour
pouvoir leur dire un petit bonjour pour
qu'ils soient tous contents de me voir
avant pour que je puisse leur dire aussi
de ne pas oublier de mettre leurs
lettres dans les boîtes afin que je
puisse leur à nous amener leurs cadeaux
des cadeaux que petits et grands
retrouveront pied du sapin le matin de
noël voilà c'est la fin de ce set 8
journal le dernier de cette année à 2017
demain vendredi
vous retrouverez nicolas kirillovitch à
la présentation est du 7-8 l'hebdo le
7-8 journal revient lui le mardi et 2
janvier 2018 d'ici là portez vous bien
très bonnes fêtes de fin d'année à tous
sur tv 78